cyclique
un nom qui sonne déjà comme au cinéma
nous sommes à château-renault en indre
et loire au siège de cet organisme dédié
au 7ème art aujourd'hui c'est jour de
réunion
c'est un petit peu une urgence et la
préparation des films de jean de la
mennais estrade je n'influence pas ce
qu'ils n'ont pas bénéficié du soutien de
la région ile de france
l'objet de cette réunion c'est de
préparer l'accueil du film de jean
xavier de lestrade jeux d'influencé qui
était donc soutenu à la production par
cycliques et l'agencement de la loi et
qui prévoit de tourner plus ou moins
entre quatre et six semaines on sait pas
encore exactement puisque en phase de
préparation de ce tournage sur le
territoire régional
l'accueil de tournages dans la région
centre c'est l'une des missions de
cyclique mais le rôle de cet organisme
financé par l'état de s'arrête pas là on
apporte un développement d'une politique
et du développement d'une communauté
d'une filière professionnelle accompagné
aussi et ça je pense que c'est
fondamental par rapport aux pouvoirs
publics c'est d'accompagner des auteurs
émergents et des des auteurs émergents
mais aussi répondre à la première
demande des producteurs de cinéma leur
trouver des lieux pour leurs tournages
une maison bourgeoise
on a les contacts évidemment du
propriétaire on a les coordonnées du
décor on cherche dans notre base de
données quelles peuvent être les maisons
qui peuvent correspondre aux critères
répétition changement de décor nous
sommes à saint georges sur cher dans
l'une de ses maisons qui sert de lieu de
tournage pour le prochain film de jean
xavier de lestrade cycliques accompagne
les films dans leurs aspects financiers
et artistique également en leur
fournissant un soutien logistique très
concret l'avantagent qui connaissent la
région déjà donc de prendre des
régisseurs ou des repéreurs de région
c'est un grand intérêt puisqu'ils
connaissent la région
donc c'est un gain de temps avec le
directeur de production donc la 3d on a
vraiment travaillé de manière assez fine
est étroite pour trouver dans chacune
des équipes techniques et les équipes
maquillage des équipes
habillage les équipes décoration les
équipes électriciens les équipes régies
seat sait trouver les compétences qu'ils
pouvaient être trouvés sur le territoire
régional pour compléter cette équipe
avec des forces vives du territoire
régional
mathieu est justement l'un des
techniciens tourangeau choisi par la
production d'un vrai côté familial au
niveau des équipes techniques
tourangelle et la région centre
en général on se connaît tous on est on
est on est quelques dizaines
décorateur
machiniste électricien régis une grosse
équipe au régime ici en touraine est on
est on est sollicité très clairement
vingt à trente films sont ainsi aidées
chaque année et ça fait 25 ans que ça
dure avec de belles distinctions pour
plusieurs d'entre eux une chance et un
atout pour faire vivre le cinéma dans la
région je suis passé à ce projet vient
aussi les élèves jardy quoi ils sont 110
m